hey everyone and welcome to biology
professor today
we're gonna have a quick video today um
before we jump into it make sure that
you hit subscribe to get free biology
study videos and also check out the link
in the description box below that is
where you can get a link to a folder
that has all of my free study notes
including pictures of the final court
so let's go ahead and get started like i
said this is going to be a fast one
today's lesson is on axenic or asanic
cultures depending on who your teacher
is you might hear it pronounced both
ways
axonic azenic something like that so i'm
going to say accident acenic cultures in
microbiology what is an actinic culture
it is a culture that contains only
one
species or sometimes even only one
strain
of a particular microorganism
many times we just call this a pure
culture
and that's the one that i would most
often say before accident is pure it
means that there are
no contaminants present
and it's often made with help of a
quadrant
streak
so a quadrant streak
um something like this i have a full
video on how to make a quadrant streak
and why it's useful so check that out if
you are interested in that and accident
cultures they also facilitate study of
of whatever the microbe is so for
example if you are familiar with cook's
postulates
i do have a video on postulates if you
want to know if that is but it relies on
having to take some sort of microbe out
of a sick
individual grow it in pure culture and
accident culture inoculated into a new
host to see if it causes the same
disease
and a lot more information in that video
on cook's postulates so basically what
it looks like is you've got some kind of
mixed culture maybe it's on a petri dish
where you can see the individual
colonies maybe it's in a mixed culture
where you just kind of see the cloudy
broth and you can't distinguish the
different isolates that are in there
but the goal is to get an accident or
pure culture where there's only one
species growing on a plate if you're
starting with a plate it's easy enough
to just like select
uh one colony and transfer it over in a
quadrant streak check out that video if
you want to know how that works if you
have a mixed culture you really have to
get it onto a plate where you can see
all the different types of colonies that
are present each type of colony
being for different isolates right
different species
and then once you've got it on a plate
again it's easy enough to just kind of
grab a colony
and
make the pure culture the accent culture
where all the colonies on this plate are
descended from like the same that should
be singular
from the same ancestor so like one
colony was taken
that colony itself is made up of
bacteria that all descended from one
colony farming unit and now you've got
your accident or pure culture that's it
for today check out my other videos grab
the free study notes the link below and
good luck with your studies see you next
time